gearbox just sent by the lady a
hammerlock pack for borderlands the
pre-sequel so we're going to take a
quick look at the Baroness class and yes
she is sir hammerlock's sister who
became very uninterested in her life in
a mansion and decided to go out into the
world of borderlands pre-sequel and star
[ __ ] macking people and her class is
pretty interesting
she's got well there's a [ __ ] Mac he's
back um she's got a tree where she
basically throws out these ice shard
crystals and at higher levels such as
what I am now level 25 uninterested
sports hunter she actually creates these
snow flurries in these snowstorms it's
pretty cool one of the niftier things
about this class is that when you go
down this cult is ice tree you're
actually encouraged to let enemies shoot
you first
because if they shoot you first you have
a full shield she'll actually throw out
her own eyes shard and damage and/or
kill the enemy so you actually do more
damage if you let them shoot first and
then you start going at it for other
skill trees do some pretty fun stuff
she's got a whole sniper dedicated skill
tree that is all about just basically
the power of sniping the benefits of
sniping a lot of games underrate sniping
and you know it's no secret I'm a huge
battlefield fan I've also been playing a
lot of destiny lately and finally on my
icebreaker in that game which
fundamentally changes your relationship
in terms of you can now snipe and enjoy
yourself so you know the guys over
gearbox recognizing players love of long
range warfare is really cool and then
her last skill tree which is more
comical than anything has to do with
having vassals vassals are just your
friends your co-op friends so what you
do is you initiate the power your friend
gives you a high-five and suddenly
they're basically your [ __ ]
and then you guys are wink together and
then all the powers at that point either
boost one of your shields and one of
your weapons or vice versa you're having
you pretty much link together until one
of you dies so I think that's kind of
their their griefing skill so yeah she's
pretty diverse in terms of Borderlands
in general not not just a pretty sequel
this is a series that I really enjoy and
it was interesting you think during our
game of year deliberations a lot of
times we talk about games in terms of
their mechanics and we don't you know
make the mechanics in their writing but
I think we a lot of times tend to favor
gameplay mechanics like shadow of Mordor
one this year largely due to its Anam
assist system and just ability to tell a
story through just the world itself
and I think Borderlands the pre-sequel
is like that too it's just this fully
realized fully fleshed out world the
lead writer Anthony Burch is just an
absolute insane person and he writes
incredible dialogue for his characters
it just it comes across so well in this
in this world you know they've got a
very cool consistent cel-shaded art
style to that lens the nature of it so
yeah when I think Borderlands I'm
usually thinking this is the game that
Bungie needs to play I'm not saying they
should emulate it because it's a little
bit too crazy for destiny style but you
know everybody in this office plays
destiny and I occasionally there's
always a lot of complaints about how the
weapons in destiny aren't diverse enough
and then I see in forums people say
things like well there's always so much
you can do with guns those people don't
know crap because they haven't played
Borderlands
Borderlands is a game that just does
everything you can possibly imagine with
weapons you've got sniper rifles you've
got laser weapons you've got this is
like a Ghostbuster gun pretty much has
Ghostbuster weapons you have weapons
that modify whether you're a de-essing
or whether you're hip firing then you
have random variation on all of your
guns so one player almost never picks up
the exact same gun is another one and
you just think about the mind ball game
on diversity that this whole series
offers you combine that with the writing
and that's what I always find attractive
so the lady hammer lock pack looks like
it's coming out January 27th for
PlayStation 3 Xbox 360 and on Steam if
you're a fan of the borderland series
and the idea of creating snow flurries
doing tons of long-range sniping and
making your friends your vassal slash
[ __ ] sounds appealing to you then you
should check it out
you